hey everybody and welcome to a Swanky
wild ride with Stevo we have got a
wildly successful comedian this week his
name's Tom Segura and what do you hear
about his private jet habit you're not
gonna believe it the guy is on fire and
this episode is hilarious informative
and it happens in Austin Texas in the
van which we drove all the way to Austin
Texas man what a wild ride and this
episode is brought to you by
kamikoto knives now if you're serious
about cooking then it's time to get
serious about your knives and these
knives are used by Michelin chefs all
over the world and these babies come in
a killer cool box with a certificate of
authenticity every knife is individually
inspected comes with a lifetime
guarantee and they're doing this crazy
sale for Black Friday where they're
really really giving you great prices
but for the listeners of the Wild Ride
podcast you get an additional 50 off any
Knife Set if you go to kamikoto.com
Stevo doesn't hurt to use the promo code
steve02 now
these things are just too much fun I
can't chop veggies enough yes
man I'm telling you
commiecodo.com
Stevo for on top of the killer sale
they're doing for Black Friday an
additional fifty dollars off any Knife
Set you want to get with its certificate
of authenticity the cool box I mean come
on Hop to it
commycodo.com Devo and now let's get
into it
ladies and gentlemen Tom Segura In the
Flesh ATX baby yeah dude I can't believe
you had this thing driven across the
halfway across the country I know we are
physically in Austin Texas and I
employed our buddy Vinnie to drive it
all the way here for this pretty cool
very cool you know how much I like you
I'm telling you this out of the top this
is how much I like you
I got a call this morning yeah
that they could fit me in for an MRI
that I need to get oh [ __ ]
this morning is this a basketball injury
related MRI we don't the the surgeon
thinks it's not related to it which is
kind of scary so it's in your knee no
it's it's coming it's stemming from my
neck and spot it's a nerve compression
he's like I want to get this Mr and
they're like we can fit you in and I was
like I gotta go see Steve what time do
you gotta tell me you gotta be there no
we moved it we're not gonna do it [ __ ]
yeah
wow it's crazy man or a pressure would
never do that part would have never done
that yeah he's selfish terrible person
he's a narcissist
yeah he just gaslights people all day oh
my God yeah sipping on a Hitler's teacup
that's an animal yeah what you really
got that off the dark web yeah I had to
I mean I didn't I can't really talk
about it I talked to some people who
knew some people you know
did you use Bitcoin
no but I used I separated myself from
the cash transactions
really yeah yeah
I mean they looked pretty similar when
you did those photos side by side of
them drinking it was his favorite cup
yeah that's what he did I mean he was
like [ __ ] Poland and he sip it and then
you saw that he I saw it it was
you know just like on TMZ it took me
forever to notice any difference
pretty much the same thing man yeah
that's very much
um so again dude here we are in Austin
Texas you've been here for what a year
and a half year and a half now yeah
um do you like it it's great man I mean
it's a total like um
it's a total change in Pace you know the
way that like I always think about it is
that like we work in chaos
yeah right like you're out you're at
shows you're at you know thousands of
people there's all kinds of crazy [ __ ]
going on
and you're coming back to a place that
for me is much more tranquil peaceful
which is a nice change from
personally I did 19 years in La which
and I and I don't dislike I still like
La a lot there's a lot of things I miss
about it a lot of things I think are rad
about la
but
I always did feel like you were leaving
like you're coming back from chaos to
kind of more chaos and this is for me is
like a like for having you know I have
two little kids
it's a very peaceful setup now I like it
I uh I donated my skateboard to one of
your kids dude he [ __ ] that kid he's
he's like our wild dude and so yeah he's
six years old he's six years old we took
him to the skate park
and um he was going off the ramp with
like a a this dude was like how long has
he even skateboarding we're like this is
his first lesson and they were like what
this guy's a [ __ ] maniac and he was
just yeah he loves it he loves it dude
thank you for that oh dude my pleasure
man it was a great way to plug my my wee
man
yeah worked out great for me merch yeah
dude
um you uh had spoken to Scott about
March right like what's going on with
the merch yeah well I think after we
spoke on the phone you're like building
a website or Is like your old website to
your new website are you interested and
yeah it went well we the guy we ended up
linking up with is the best
I don't even know if I linked you up
with them did I I don't know I don't
remember okay I don't remember yeah it
was a couple it was during the pandemic
when everything was taken off and we
were trying to find a merged person too
but I mean that that was our one
connection then you had my brother on
your podcast talking about bukaki your
brother you know here's the thing that
I'll never forget about your brother
when when he was telling me one of the
things he was telling me was that
you know he he was like I was on he was
on heroin yep and he was he kept saying
this thing that
that has never left me which was he had
a job he had like I think real estate or
something and he was like you know I
kept like I couldn't I couldn't get it
to get like I would show up late or I
would forget the thing
I you know where I would so I was
supposed to be here but I just I
couldn't get it together right and ever
and I remember him telling me all this
stuff and for some reason
it's like when someone says something
and dots connect all the times in my
life where I've thought about somebody
being like that and you want to go the
[ __ ] is going on with you man it made me
go like oh maybe that person was on
drugs and that and that like drugs where
you go falling down strung out clearly
on drugs it was he was doing drugs but
still
you know participating in like trying to
work and those kind of people always
made me crazy where you're like dude
it's [ __ ] 10 o'clock like where are
you and he kept telling me how he was
like every time I had an appointment or
I was supposed to do something I would
just like [ __ ] it up somehow but it was
because
I was either on heroin or looking for
heroin or trying to get heroin and it's
never left me I think about it all the
time about all the times that you're
trying to like you know get something
done with someone and you're like what
is wrong with you yeah there's your
Spidey senses are going off in their
dish they're disheveled and there's like
unmanageability they're eight minutes
late for everything [ __ ] sorry
they're like sweating it's like and that
was like he was like oh yeah that was
that was heroin yeah that was me like
trying to get through life but having
heroin pulled me in this direction yeah
it's probably safe to say that if
somebody's like that there's definitely
something pulling them in that where
it's not a priority right exactly
exactly you know because it's like that
doesn't like
you're sober I mean that's sober but
like yeah yeah but not on you're on
point you know you're you're business
savvy and like you tell us to get here
at a certain time you're here we're here
it's like we got [ __ ] to do everybody
you kind of you know but like there's
also like people and this is like we're
all you know friends and doing this but
like what also like when you hire
someone or you're like hey you know like
hey man show me this property and the
person's like
not answering and then there's the [ __ ]
are you doing their address is off
slightly and you're like dude you're a
real estate guy what the [ __ ] is that
happening how are you not doing this you
know yeah but for so like for some
reason he has been that story for me is
one of those things that is like it's a
file in my head ever since he said it I
I always think of it when somebody is
off yeah I'm like maybe this person's on
drugs yeah he'll be super happy to know
that too well I mean he and also I'll
tell you this as somebody I saw him do
stand up
um at the store like
I don't know five years ago and I was
like oh you know there's kernels of like
a funny guy here and stuff and then I've
seen him on Instagram posting clips now
he has gotten like light years better
yeah he's gotten really good yeah he's
been he's been practicing a lot and he
just had a kid too I didn't know that he
and Chelsea him and Chelsea yeah yeah
and I was gonna ask you about that too
is um you know because you started
killing it before you had kids or did
your trajectory start taking off because
like we were like we're not having kids
right until we can pay for kids right I
always thought that was a [ __ ]
because we had so many friends in stand
up who like like even Bert Prince you
know like he's one of those guys as a
kid is like a feature act making a
hundred dollars you know a show and I
was like uh-uh and I wanted kids I was
the opposite of like a lot of couples
where I was the guy being like I want
kids
and Christina was like
we're gonna have kids on what we make
this is [ __ ] crazy and and I knew
like other comics
who had you know they had their kids at
like 22 and they're out there doing and
I'm like I was like I mean that was the
part that I I didn't I didn't fight back
on that I was like
you know I don't mind
I don't think I feel like you have to be
like doing extraordinarily well to have
kids but I didn't want to be at the
level I was at at the time which is a
feature Act of making a hundred dollars
a show yeah and that is before I pay for
my plane ticket you're like dude so I'm
guessing that the six-year-old is the
younger one no no he's the older oh yeah
because you've been killing it for a lot
longer than that well actually you know
the he was born we decided we could
start planning to have a kid after
uh like we could start planning to have
a kid and then he came along you know uh
two like about two years later okay so
like in other words
started to do like I probably could have
been like we could have a kid
2013 2014 it became clear like this
trajectory is going
better like and and like hey we can
start looking to do that and then he was
born at the end of 2015. so it was like
you know it was like solidified like
Okay We're not gonna be like oh my God
how are we gonna pay rent this month
yeah and then we started planning to
have a kid but really he'll be seven
yeah because I I mean the dream of yours
is to do to do comedy like were you
worried that having a kid would like
crush your dreams yes
now in order to have children you gotta
have sex in order to have sex you gotta
have a boner now if you want to have a
raging boner then it's time to look into
Bluetooth tablets why because they've
got the same active ingredient as both
Viagra and Cialis except they only cost
a fraction of the price and if you're
wondering do blue chew tablets mean
having a lot of fun the answer is yes
just ask my girl because when I chew up
my Bluetooth tablets I declare war on
her vagina yeah with my weiner huge
boner time I'm telling you and for the
listeners of the Wild Ride podcast if
you go to bluetooth.com and use the
promo code Stevo they will send you an
entire month's supply of Bluetooth
tablets all you gotta pay is five
dollars for shipping plus when you get
to the website and consult with the
medical provider you take care of the
prescription very simply very easily
without any awkward visit to a doctor's
office it's so convenient and again
Bluetooth tablets are so fun just
between me and you guys
um I just got home I haven't seen Lux in
12 days I'm taking her to Bone town and
I'm taking her to Bone town with some
Bluetooth tablets you're out of your
mind if you don't jump on this deal it's
bluechew.com with the promo code Stevo
for an entire month ply of Bluetooth
tablets all you got to pay is five
dollars for shipping you and your boner
are gonna thank me so jump on that and
let's talk about kids in order to make
you work harder well but both both I
think both happen when you have a kid
you start to go like oh like your
immediate thing is like well I'm no
longer cool because you're like when
you're out and you're like drinking
partying you're just like this you have
no resp nothing you know I can go to bed
at [ __ ] four in the morning all
sudden you go if I have a kid am I gonna
be like a dad comic who's like diapers
you know and like my shit's gonna be
automatically lame like that's your fear
but the other thing that happens I think
for I think it's almost like in our DNA
is like
the second it's like your your your you
know your spouse starts showing and
you're like oh there's a [ __ ] baby
that I'm responsible for you go into
like this like a hunter-gathering yeah
hustle mode where it's like a drive that
you didn't know even existed in you you
know which is like so focused to be like
I have to provide yeah yeah I had a guy
ask me one time if I you know I was like
30 and he's like are you you have kids
and he's like a middle eastern guy and I
said
so no dude I still got a lot of stuff I
want to do with my life and he's like
what are you talking about I was like
you know I want to make money and this
and that and he was like so shocked and
he's like in the Middle Eastern culture
the more kids you have the more money
you make it's a good omen yeah there's a
lot of people I still remember Al
Madrigal I was like I'm Madrigal was
telling me I was like I think I was
telling him this was before we were
having him he was like don't you want
kids
because he had kids young too
and or he had his young and and I was
like yeah but you know this and that he
goes it was he was kind of like that he
goes the universe will provide
so if you have kids he goes
it it just provides you're gonna be fine
do it do it people used to have kids so
that when they were old elderly that
they would have these kids to take care
of them yeah and then now it's like the
kids are just baggage and burdened and
and the elderly are taking care of their
kids like forever and people in like
American culture is kind of sad on how
we treat our elderly
Japanese you know where they just like
honor it scared they wash their parents
feet every morning before they get out
of bed and we just get them out of our
sight like it's a party Foul to be old
yeah it sucks that's really sad I know
and because I I actually still really
dig like
you know you're just like run into some
old old dude and just chat him up and
you're like this was like the best even
if it's like a five minute combo like
just the knowledge the stories the fun
of those and like I feel like
most of them are like someone's talking
to me right you know almost like a
homeless you know like a homeless person
I'll be like thanks for talking to me
right like old people will be like hey
thanks that's why I'm so scared of of
old age yeah because to be an old
attention [ __ ] yeah yeah like yes where
you need to be the center of attention
but nobody wants to pay attention to old
people so true because old people are
are a reminder of mortality absolutely
and nobody wants to think about their
mortality they want to have their
blinders on and just like la la la la I
know you get every year I mean I don't
know if it happens to you but like every
year I get older there's this part of
you that has to go like oh like I am
inching closer right right like you
don't want to like spend all day
thinking about it right then you know
like you get phone calls like hey we
just need to go over this whole life
insurance policy you got yeah like all
right and then they're like so if you go
you're like oh [ __ ] like you have life
insurance oh I got massive life
insurance wow yeah the beneficiaries is
a scary word and [ __ ] yeah and it
gets like I mean then there's like all
these little
types of like I've had different
policies and like
it's yeah it's a it's a very morbid
topic but then you start going like you
have the conversation
and in my case you finish the phone call
and then you like turn around and you
see your kids and you're like right yeah
I kind of gotta sure set this up you
know has your premium for life insurance
uh gone down with your weight
[Laughter]
I just I mean I just got a new policy
and um I have a call about it's like
it's a new type of insurance that I've
never I think has my tour so big they're
like oh we can get you into this big
baller life insurance program now so I
think it's um I don't know what it's
gonna be but I think I'm in a better
place for sure for not being huge and
fat yeah yeah and and uh I mean dude get
like if you look at your your catalog of
specials yeah and like hey you were a
bigger boy well you're getting more
handsome as you get older it's just dude
I mean I wish I could
I get mad at myself about it because
like I like I hate I almost you ever
like resent that something's part of
your story
like I like I was I resent my attempt at
becoming a rapper yeah yeah like you
hate that it's a footnote
like I almost like I almost resent you
know my own struggles with weight just
because just because I know it's not um
it wasn't a disease it's not like I'm
not genetically like oh if I eat it's
just from being an overeating
uh sedentary person you know I mean like
yeah but dude is that because like
because I get like that as well
touring on the road like you're in a
hotel room like you kind of want to
comfort eat yeah you know what it really
is it was not it was not dealing with
emotions
in a healthy way I just like an
emotional eater and I would just stuff
myself and like
eat like an [ __ ] and not exercise and
then you go like hey how'd you change
that well I started eating healthier and
exercise like it's it's so simple that
that it almost just a shame that you're
not in a shame spiral of like
masturbating in a hotel room oh yeah
which was food yeah you just go to bed
take a nap before the show for three
hours that's exactly what and I also
feel like that is um part of that is
actually the um when you don't know
what's going to happen with your life
when you when you're fully signed up for
stand up like fully signed up for stand
up at like 20
so you realize you're like 26 27 so
you know everyone started their careers
kind of out of college that that you
know that I yeah and they're like you're
like all right now I'm like four or five
years removed from that I've been and
now I'm in
and I'm
I'm making a hundred dollars a show
I'm doing six shows
and I have to pay for my plane ticket
and you know like I'm gonna go home with
like two hundred dollars
and I think the the anxiety of of almost
like this is crazy would be a
masturbation
food binging lay around all day kind of
cycle yeah that would yeah it would be
like
I I seem to recall a bit in one of your
earlier specials about
masturbating in hotel rooms oh yeah yeah
yeah I mean all that [ __ ] was like this
is what I'm do I'm talking about and
they always say like talk about what you
know I'm like this is what I'm this is
what I'm doing like right and then like
yeah I would I and I remember like
I was I remember lying about my weight
in that special
in that special I say it I say I'm 245
well I remember I do I say I'm 245. I'm
255 in that special and I say I'm 245
because I'm I think I'm more comfortable
lying about those 10 pounds
and then
on the next special
where I'm actually doing like my careers
going better
I'm and I remember I had a gym
membership and I hired at this like the
trainer I'm working out more and I'm I'm
actually like a little bulkier but I'm
eating more I'm actually like 263 in the
next one
and I'm like just and I and then I
remember the end of that like that
special that tour comes out and I got on
a scale and I was I saw I was 268 and I
was like holy [ __ ] this is like really
getting towards the the big three zero
zero that you don't want to hit and
that's when I was like
but even then it was like you know it's
always been like up down well I it seems
that it's the opposite because you know
you lost the weight and have kept it off
like you didn't well I think when you're
the person you you're so fixated on
right little amounts because I actually
got a lot I lost a bunch of weight for
the the special that came out called
disgraceful which came out in 2018 then
I gained 20 pounds which doesn't sound
crazy but the next special that came out
I'm 20 pounds heavier
and I was so ashamed of that so ashamed
of that because like I was so happy
about where I had been before and and
then that special came out then I got
injured
um later that year with the basketball
thing
and that was the thing that really when
I got out of the hospital I was like
I was like man I gotta I gotta finally
try to be consistently healthy like
meaning like not just go pick a number
like because that's the I think that's
the big [ __ ] up for people that are like
trying to manage weight is you go this
is just stick to the number it's like
you gotta just be consistent in your
maintenance it's not about being like I
need to be
to 10 or two like whatever the number is
it's like saying no I gotta Just Eat
Right and exercise and like not be a
piece of [ __ ] yeah all the time and that
that's the difference from now is that I
just try to be consistent with like yeah
what do you do yeah what's your exercise
of choice
um right now I kind of so I mix it up I
have I have a Peloton bike so I do like
I like that for like like on cardio days
I have kettlebells
um I like doing kettlebell circuits you
know so like you do like swings goblets
press like you kind of mix up split
squats and then on the road I bring a
trainer so that's really the game
changers
I bring Sean Nix who's like this super
fit like dude who he's like he's he's
with me like he's like this every day on
the road so it's like he orders lunch
I ordered lunch with him he's like when
are we going to the gym we work out
every day and you're traveling on a tour
bus yeah we fly and then usually the bus
meets us where we fly and then you know
we're in hotels but like you know we
also it's like some hotels have like
these unbelievable gyms some have dog
[ __ ] gyms yeah sometimes there's no gym
and they go there's a [ __ ] you know
like a orange theory down the street
yeah so we just do what we do you know
we bring
we bring our uh boxing equipment that we
might box one day but we never we
basically we have no we don't we really
have no days off you know so we just
consistently do things what's your uh uh
writer like for food
food it's um my green room has turkey
slices no carbs yeah veggie platter yeah
I mean most days I have yogurt and
blueberries every morning for breakfast
then I have like egg whites and turkey
and then
um we have protein shakes usually every
day 50 grams protein in a shake
and then you know we do a lot of chicken
leaner Cuts I used to always eat like I
went to a steakhouse I'd be like what's
the biggest [ __ ] rib eye you have and
I would like
stuff my like it would hurt and I would
be like you have to fit like crazy [ __ ]
yeah I feel crazy and now it's like oh
no I'll have the eight ounce thing and
I'll be like fully charred rare with
veggies I mean I feel fine with that
yeah it's it's just like do you have a
sauna no I'm one of the only guys in my
circle of friends and everybody's a huge
are you a Sonic guy too no we were
talking about it and uh because I'm
dying to know everybody has sauna
everybody and I've been dying to get a
sauna and I'm about to get Asana the
problem is nobody talks about what sauna
they get because there's certain saunas
that like all the research is done at
175 degrees and higher
but I don't know what San is the best
and I was hoping that you had one so you
could tell me which one I'm okay so I am
building my own gym yeah because I want
to have some [ __ ] that I don't I can't
do at my house so I bought a building
and I'm building my own gym and I am
getting a sauna in there and I'm going
to consult with a couple friends about
which one to get yes what about because
and I just bought the Morosco Forge ice
bath
I got a cold Plunge at the house yeah I
like that
if you ask me it's cold enough already I
mean Winter's here and with winter comes
the holidays and with the holidays comes
a whole lot of e-commerce and I'm
telling you the only way that we can
ship our autographed Wee Man and Stevo
skateboards to fill the demand is with
ship station and if you're not selling
stuff online then allow me to report
that you're blowing it and especially
with the holidays man everybody's out
there just making tons of money and
they're doing it a lot easier with this
the help of ship station it's one
interface that's super uh intuitive easy
to use brings together all of your
different methods of selling if you're
selling on Amazon
Etsy on your own website it's all in one
interface and it brings in all of your
shipping services is the United States
Post Office UPS FedEx plus they hook you
up with rates that are normally reserved
for Fortune 500 companies they just give
you the best deals on shipping they make
it all easy to use you print out your
labels and it's all off and running plus
if you go to
shipstation.com then hit the microphone
in the top right corner plug in the
promo code Stevo and you're off and
running with the 60-day free trial it's
so awesome and every single thing that I
ship from my e-commerce online store I
ship with ship station I swear by it my
business is a success because of it and
I'm telling you that you're out of your
mind if you don't jump on the 60-day
free trial for hassle free totally
convenient shipping telling you time to
make ship happen so go to
shipstation.com top right corner hit the
microphone plug in the promo code Stevo
and you're Off to the Races now let's
talk about this cold plunge
you do you like it no but do you love it
afterwards yes
yeah it is a good and you know what
really helped me get through it so I
remember like when I first got it I was
like
all right you know what's the um like I
just looked up like what you know what
like what's the minimum you're supposed
to try to get to it everybody's like you
want to do three minutes
you know start if you can't do that try
to do two try to do a minute you know
whatever
so I get in
I started at like 50 degrees which
people don't even respect it like cold
plunge right and I did my three minutes
and then
I was like all right I kept doing three
minutes and I started to lower the
temperature
I was just trying to figure out like how
can I I don't know
do better at this or whatever
you know Wim Hof yeah sure he has this
YouTube video that's um just a breathing
exercise video it has like 40 million
views okay like 40 million and it's him
literally it's not even his face it's
his voice taking you through a breathing
exercise in out now and he's like and
he's got it's a guided breathing
exercise
and you see numbers as the breath is is
animated right
I did it with him with do it so I put
that on top of the like the you know the
cold plunge cover as I was sitting there
and then I kind of just and then he's
like now take this break now let's do
the next sequence
and I was designed for breathing while
you're in a cold it's actually you can
use it for that or just um guided
breathing even like if you want to just
like start your day
you know like because it has multiple
benefits but it's particularly helpful
in that setting and in the cold plunge
setting I think
first time I do it with him in like 47
degree water six minutes because I
wasn't even I was lost
in the breath guidance so like highly
recommend if you're going to try that or
if you're trying to improve to pull up
that video and just let you won't even
be aware of time it's just you just have
Wim Hof taking you through it yeah you
got a cold plan it's been sitting in my
front yard for literally months I don't
even know how many months a lot of
months I haven't even tried it yet try
it I haven't even tried it yet and the
last I heard was that like inside it's
just like
growing mold yeah we gotta we gotta
figure she doesn't have that treated
yeah but do you notice the difference in
your sleeping and all that with after
the cold do you notice any difference
from it oh my god well the the first
thing is like
when you get out and in the moments
afterward I uh after there's all types
of actual chemical
um releases going on yeah your brain is
releasing a number of real
um endorphins and like yeah what is it
Noreen epinephrine yes all that is
actually so you do have this sense of
like Euphoria and and like
I mean you you feel like you invigorated
yes you're very invigorated yeah well
it's a dope feeling it really is all
right I don't have to try it because
that's a whoop strap right yeah and
are you noticing good recoveries after
you do ice bath like which when you wake
up in the morning what's your percentage
of recovery normally it's been rough for
me lately it has been my travel and and
I'm on 99 recovery
and I'm like
34.99 today I got last night I went to
bed like aberrationally early
so I did like I'm normally like a night
guy and I just tapped at it but dude
like we will have a call with whoop and
Steve's like yeah my HRV recovery is
like 140 and they're like what like
triathletes don't even have that that is
incredible what do you what do you
attribute that to
um it's it's how good of a job I'm doing
at avoiding sugar really yeah I noticed
that like when I cut out sugar my HIV
goes way up
my um that is my you know everybody had
like when I was used to I used to want
to just like lose weight people would go
like cut out your drinking and I'm like
yeah I don't really drink and then
they'll just go oh
yes thanks for the advice how about Bert
yeah
my whoop recovery is off the charts he's
so proud of his tequila Discovery I mean
he really feel he really feels like he
made like like like a Doctor Who's like
you know what is causing cancer like he
feels like he made an actual Landmark
Discovery with tequila yeah all the
comments on our on the video that I
posted about that clip he was like yeah
that's an alcoholic talking right there
oh yeah he's like and he's like telling
he's like here's what you need to do you
don't need to stop drinking you need to
start drinking tequila like he's really
yeah proud of this and I'm like you
think that's what it is he's like a
hundred percent
so out of his mind
um now for me I've noticed
so much of how my life is like how
everything in this shell is affected by
Sugar yeah if I dude like it's not just
weight digestion like inflammation and
everything mood and if I and I can have
this like
thing where I won't have I could I'll
have incidental incidental sugars are
what I call like you know this thing has
two grams of sugar in it right you're
like whatever but I mean if you go like
I want sugar like I want a brownie or
whatever you know I mean like a donut
I can have that and be like fine but if
you go like
let's have another one and let's have
one tomorrow like and I build a pattern
it it only within a couple days I notice
a complete transformation like a
complete downward spiral and
like we're both like
addicts in every sense of the word so
like if I open that cage door a little
crack the whole gorilla comes out sugar
is my favorite one it's my favorite one
it's not it's the number one drug in the
world it is yeah and I can like people
go like if you had to like you know like
because high fat is very satiating right
like something like rich and for sure
and butter and unlike of course
delicious but if you go me like give me
the option I'll be like oh sugar sugar
every time yeah like on the way here I
had a headache I woke up in the morning
had coffee whatever had a headache and
then I was like man I need to eat
something and they had mango dehydrated
mango in the front on the way here and I
and I ate a couple my headache went away
and I'm like 22 grams of sugar for a
[ __ ] dehydrated mango I'm like I just
drank a Coke yeah my headache's gone
I think it's Sugar's incredible it's
incredible that they think that like
when I went taking tours of the the
Mayan ruins they were like dude these
[ __ ] ruins were around for 10 000
years or 5 000 years and then when the
British came when they invented when
they started like teaching them how to
mill for sugar everybody's scattered
because they the diseases started
happening and diabetes and people
started dying off that they thought the
land was cursed so they left but really
what happened was
they started teaching them how to like
make rum from all the sugar cane and
[ __ ] and like they left within 100 Years
of that happening because everybody
started dying of diseases unbelievable I
mean sugar sugar man yeah it is it's
deadly in Texas people are healthier I
guess California is a pretty high
Baseline for yeah
yeah I mean
Texans feel more like
I mean you know this also Austin's kind
of an anomaly when you say Texas because
like sure it really is like a unique
place I mean this had this has this is
the city that has the hippies and the
plant-based people on top of obviously
you still have like your barbecue and
all that stuff but right it is kind of a
unique
it's kind of nashvilly yeah and and port
Portland yeah like the horn Keep Austin
Weird I mean it's the blue City in a red
state it really is you know I mean this
is like you you can go
30 miles outside of the city and you
feel like you're in a different country
right so yeah I mean yeah I taped my
first special in Austin you did we're at
at the Paris oh it's great it's a great
spot yeah I uh you guys were doing a
live podcast there we did we did it last
year yeah it was fun
super fun
podcasting
um
like getting guests is that
I thought it was gonna be
more challenging than it is deep
piggyback on on people flying in to do
Rogan at all no I really and I thought
that was going to be a thing and I
didn't want it to be but I also you kind
of just have like this acceptance It's
been
it's been its own like no people are
flying in to do our show flying into
dude epic man yeah I mean I just had
Tarantino on and he didn't do he did
Rogan a couple months ago but like or
last year
um but I mean is Tarantino promoting a
book yeah okay oh yeah yeah he is that's
right so he had like but he came in did
our show and like
I mean I've had a bunch of comics that
like they're just booked we you know we
fly we've flown people in we've had
people you know it's just like we also
find out who's coming to town like we do
it that way and you know Joe's thing too
is it's it's such a juggernaut like what
he has is so it's so its own unique on a
rocket ship thing that like you know I
never thought of it as like I've never
thought of it as like I'm competing with
him or anything like that it's like
he does this thing he also has an
incredibly full schedule too yeah where
it's like [ __ ] out I'm like a month or
two in advance do you have a Booker we
use so we've we've used like we have
internally we have people that book and
then we also sometimes use an external
booking service for certain people but
like also the agencies will help like
you know like your agents yeah we'll
kind of figure out like
you know who who they think would be a
good fit who might be willing to and I
have like a lot of um
started to even I'll find out somebody
that I wanna man I'd love to podcast
with this person get their information
and start even personally reaching out
to people yeah do that too Pierce
[Laughter]
he's the best yeah he's the best I I um
spoke with him
uh since since of doing her podcast and
uh you know I was like okay like here's
the deal I think that uh my episode with
you was supposed to come out the one
week but it came out a week later so he
wasn't privy to to everything I
discussed about my future plans and so I
I've filled him in All uh you know in in
person okay so this is what it is like
uh I'm in his wheelhouse yeah yeah yeah
yeah no you guys are like yeah I'm in
his wheels he's so fun and he's so
creative like dude every time we
announce a new live show which is like
our ticketed event you know which is
like the no rules right right right
crazy
um streaming show he puts together a
pitch deck dude I'm like he's a
professional yeah he's made multiple
pitch decks for me yeah and you're like
yeah he's like yeah and then this will
be on the back of a semi and it'll be
driven into my [ __ ]
he's really yeah
yeah I know I've said this on other
podcasts but I am always I mean I think
you probably have uh discovered the same
thing I'm always taken by how almost
everybody I've met in the adult industry
are like the kindest like nicest most
down-to-earth people that I've worked
like they're always so friendly yeah I
want to get a porn star on this show and
I cannot wait to start training with
them yeah training my [ __ ] train your
[ __ ] nobody can get it ready like he
can right yeah and uh he was just
describing to me like the
the you you have like an outer butthole
and an inner butthole and you have to
start training the inner butthole
but that's how things get stuck
in the inner butthole yeah are you ready
for this
I'm gonna give it hell dude yeah yeah so
everybody he described getting some
some serious objects in there I bet well
you can get a fist up there that is
[ __ ] wild to me that is something I
don't want anything to do with either I
have zero interest I've had fingers in
there that's the most well yeah I mean
I've had you know yeah a finger in there
yeah
sure but a fist I have zero interest in
right I I I don't I even here's the
thing like I've had a finger in there
and I've been like I want to and like
I'm not trying to not enjoy this
but I almost felt like the more joy came
from
the moments before the figure you know I
mean like the outer rim of course that's
where all the nerve endings are yeah but
the inside wasn't as thrilling to you
put another one no no but I was like
like are you having fun I'm like I think
so yeah and I want it to be fun but yeah
I think that's how girls feel I guess
like you know the first three times you
do anal it's horrible yeah and then
after that it's the best thing ever
really that's that's so I've heard so
you've heard
so it's probably like that with uh with
the finger new big angle guy no I like
the idea of it yeah like the the idea of
how dirty it is right is cool but like
the reality of it it's like no there's a
piece of [ __ ] in there yeah or you know
something like that not too concerned
with it yeah
um so so we were dying to ask you of of
the flying that you do yeah what
percentage of it is on private jets
these days
God damn it
it's pretty high seems like somebody
feels a little bit guilty about their
private jet habit and maybe they could
use some therapy the good news is that
this episode is brought to you by
betterhelp.com which is the largest
online therapy service in the world and
maybe it's like serious things that you
got to work out relationship problems
problems with your boss maybe that's
tough to talk to about like with so you
don't know where to turn well
betterhelp.com takes all of that out of
the equation and they've matched over
three million people with professionally
licensed vetted qualified therapists and
I will tell you myself I am in therapy
and I feel very strongly about the
benefits of it so for you if you wanna
you make it even more affordable than it
already is
betterhelp.com that's better
h-e-l-p.com slash Stevo will give you 10
off your first month and I really think
it's worth giving it a shot like I said
we've all got things that are difficult
to talk about we don't know where to
turn to and with betterhelp.com you're
taking a very simple questionnaire they
match you up with the right therapist
for you and boom you're Off to the Races
so one more time go to betterhelp.com
Stevo that's better h e l p.com slash
Devo for 10 off your first month I swear
by it and I think you will too now let's
talk about these private jets
yes are you ashamed of that I mean it's
a little you're a little embarrassed by
it but also well here's here's the real
like the absolute real real truth of
this
the tour that I have been on I'm coming
everywhere yes
yeah I'm coming everywhere World Tour
is literally I'm talking logistically
logistically impossible to do this about
like this these shows if you look at the
weeks and the amount of shows of the
amount of cities you could not I I would
I would have to reduce the tour to do it
commercially it wouldn't be the same
tour it literally you can't go I'm doing
Kansas City Cheyenne Eugene
Ottawa Providence you know like you
wouldn't be able to do it commercially
like the only way you can do that
touring is to Charter because you're
literally going from the show to the
airport to fly to the city so that
you're there like you'd have to do three
connections on some of those we would
miss flights now I don't do every flight
like that
um there's there's weeks where we go all
right
I'll fly the you know it was like I was
flying to Toronto and I was like you
know what I'll leave the day before and
fly commercially it was no big deal if I
fly to LA from Austin there's so many
flights I'm like I'll take a commercial
flight but on the the routing of the
tour it's mostly Charter yeah
do can you fly Charter doing theaters
does it make sense economically it
depends two theaters a night
yes or like if you were consistently
selling out two theaters a night would
it make sense to fly private
and and the answer would be well it
really is and it depends scenario
because
what I mean by theater like first of all
there's different size theaters like all
this is very so it's like 3000 and above
you probably can yes if you're doing 3
000 seats a theater that's a pretty good
sized theater that means you're doing 6
000 tickets a night and you're doing
that a few nights like three nights a
week four nights a week yeah you could
do it you still would probably it's so
expensive you would still probably go
back and forth meaning like you take the
commercial ones when it makes sense it
is extraordinarily expensive but here's
the thing the way you if you look at it
like the way I'm explaining you're
taking that Charter flight to make money
it's not just for like the flex or the
luxury of the flight you're actually
going like this flight is allowing me to
go make money in this other yeah you
know that's our goal we want to do it
you know are you still getting burnt out
flying private uh the same way you would
commercial or not the same I mean you
the the biggest convenience you find
from a charter flight people you usually
think of it as like when you see it you
you know you see the inside of it you're
like oh my God it is the fact that when
the flight's at 10 A.M you could pull up
at 9 45. and that when you land you
literally go from the tarmac to the
hotel it's the time saving yeah yeah
it's like it feels like
um I'm sleeping all the way reclined oh
yeah and also like sleeping in that
morning instead of getting up three
hours before you need to be at the
airport so like it's it's that you
actually feel like you time travel like
you land you like I can't believe we
we're here now like you know we're like
or you're in the next city you're
performing in two hours after the show
that just ended in another city so
you're like oh we're here now like you
can't believe that you're there that
quickly that's the part of it that
becomes you're like this is so great I
don't want to give this up but it is
it is
extremely expensive yeah yeah when
you're doing your uh tour bus legs yeah
is your tour bus these days wrapped with
obnoxious burnt stuff no
it is completely discreet yeah yeah I uh
I I I I knew from day one I would not be
that guy because I am I don't want
right who's in there I'm the opposite
you know and the [ __ ] first time I
saw Bert's bus I was like
I was like you're gonna have everybody
knocking out he goes no and then he
called me he's like dude people are
knocking on the door I go yeah it's got
your face on it bro I the last time I
spoke to burden here yeah I cursed him
it was the bastard I saw you doing it
[ __ ] wrapped my bus of course if you
[ __ ]
of course yeah we have Steve has the
sign that says it's not okay to knock
yeah it's not okay to knock please do
not disturb and and it's on a motion
sensor so when they're walking up to
like yeah that's you have that that that
that diminishes it but it's not
eliminated but like I know that you at
least have that like hey respect me
um Bert doesn't have that he his sign
might be like go ahead and knock
yeah crazy yeah yeah but let me tell you
the machine story oh my God
he sits him down he's like when I was 22
years old
okay
uh how much time does bird spend in
Austin like
um he I mean you know it's not easy
obviously like he's he's made a huge
sacrifices for it but
yeah he comes in and we try to do
we try to bank you know I mean the show
we always try to make the show is the
two of us we do we call it guest Bears
because we just have to now but like
he'll come in
guest Bears meaning meaning someone sits
in for for one of the two of us so like
I was I was a guest with him yeah and
like this week you know him he and Neil
Brennan are on
um and then like I just had Jana like
you know so people come in so that we
don't we never want to go dark for a
week right right right right
um but like he'll come in he just he was
in town we recorded four together he's
coming in town next month and we'll do
four to we'll do four over two days so
basically we'll do a month of shows in
two days
um
try to do something together so we have
like an activity or something something
fun to do but yeah I mean you know it's
just the way to keep the show going it's
two bears does it do bigger numbers than
your mom's house about the same they
vary I mean like some weeks
um your mom's house will do better some
weeks two bears I think the um
consistently it's huge the most they're
both pretty big they're both pretty big
I mean the yeah it just depends I mean
but they're both pretty solid like big
big shows yeah yeah I mean Bert's gotta
feel a little bit sad about how bertcast
does compared no it's not even close
yeah no it's this Bert flat private yes
a lot yes but I fly in much better
aircraft
yeah we we uh just a Canada tour and um
for my Newton Newfoundland shows yeah I
was liked it and I'm going private yes
I'm on your guys heels man I've been uh
dude when you um I've been I've been um
doing theaters where even like birds
coming up you know like yeah yeah like
uh the electric science like Stevo's
tonight like birds you know yeah next
month yeah yeah I'm even in the mix on
the same theater that's rad dude
congratulations thank you super stoked
do you you see more sellout tickets from
like a swipe up or from like promoting
it on the podcast
or do you are you like reluctant to do
that or are you like no let's sell out
[ __ ] boom let's do a swipe up and
like hey there's still tickets left in
Phoenix does that like if there's still
tickets left you know
that's usually a post I think you know
like when they're like hey there's if
you want to do a post there's there's
tickets left for Friday's show that's a
post
um usually podcast stuff is more like
announce stuff you know like yeah
these are the shows coming up and then
that has its own effect but the posts
usually work for like trying to clean up
a show you know yeah all right yeah I
mean I'm a very gun shy about promoting
Tour on social media why because I just
feel like uh
it's like they had I want my engagement
to be strong I want what I post to be
like super popular on there and if it
feels too
promotional I feel like that
solicitation it's going to turn people
off I don't think so because you do
enough that isn't that that you've
bought yourself
yeah the yeah the opening to do okay
yeah I feel like Instagram was like that
a couple years ago but now it's like it
just needs content like your people are
like starving I mean I'm the I look I'm
terrible I I don't particularly
like I'm I'm not a
a a good social media manager you know
like I I mean like I think you like like
Bert for instance I mean I'll give him
full credit you know his tour promos are
great he's the promo King he you know
content you do great content you know
I'm I'm more reluctant I just go like
you know I find that the stuff that does
the highest engagement for me is
anything that is truly an organic thing
which is usually actually a still it's a
still with a comment right those do the
biggest things for me by far I mean yeah
and like like grievously [ __ ]
yourself up playing basketball
that will do very well that would
actually actually made me an incredible
amount of money but
the the uh you know like I I do a lot of
promotional stuff and I just kind of
like meaning like new podcast Clips here
they are announcement of things here
they are because I kind of go like this
is a promotional tool and then I'll tell
myself like all right you know
um you know like I ran into Steve I'll
put that up and that'll do huge
engagement it's just it's like it's it's
just a photo and a caption and it's kind
of like all right this is not a this is
not a um I'm not saying click here it's
just right right this is just a photo
um and I think those are important to
have but I think you do so much content
that you've bought yourself the Goodwill
to promote whatever you want you know I
think once you get fake tits that's
gonna be a fun promotion
are you getting fake tits yeah that's
great it doesn't look good on you yeah
it's uh I mean who wouldn't want to go
see him on tour taking a photo with his
titties how long will they be I'm only
planning on keeping them in for three
months in you're gonna actually get them
in I'm gonna okay I'm gonna get it what
other kind of effect that's what you're
talking about I thought you were talking
about like a prosthetic I'm [ __ ]
getting breast augmentation surgery pal
what gave you this idea and and I'm and
I'm told that that I can do D or damn
Double D so you know I only heard Double
D
wait what made you do this
um it's the next logical step for me and
the the the the gone that's where that
that's where the bar is at bro that's
where the bar they've gone too far yeah
I was going to sleep last night at 8 30
p.m and I was thinking about Tim I was
like dude I could get Tim Kennedy to
hook up the sniper
snipers sniper's tits off
laughs
you you can have them on your mom's
house when he's got the titties I would
love that are you gonna change your
pronouns no no no no no identify as a
heterosexual guy okay cisgender male
white male yeah this is it's
um
heterosexual guys
that's what I'm told man I got uh I'm
developing man boobs dude I can fit him
holy [ __ ] dude yeah that's why and when
you know when you're doing it
um whenever my next special comes out
and then
and then you'll have the obviously the
removal done at the after the yeah it's
from my next tour is the gone too far
tour
that's where Pierce is going to come
into play I think this is going to do so
well you're gonna be on nothing but PJs
that's kind of what I'm thinking I got I
got the connect for you by the way when
you wanna pull the trigger when you get
your titties he's got to connect
yeah holy [ __ ] dude yeah it's it's good
stuff man
um
how's married life dude you know it's
it's good I um I will say that embarking
on a tour like I did is not helpful okay
it's not good for home life right right
you're just gone I was gone too much
yeah I think if I um I mean I talked to
my agent about it I was like yo this
next I'm not gonna tour for a minute I'm
not like one of these guys that finishes
the tour and announces my you know what
rhyme and I want to take some time off
to chunk together your next job yeah I I
like that's how I work I I for sure I
work you know hey let's start over I go
to a club I start working it out and
like I um
I already told him I was like next tour
you know Bill Burr style 60 cities but
spread it out yeah I'm not doing you
know this tour I'm on dude I
I mean it started in August of 21. it'll
end May 15 of 23 and it's going to end
up being
like
I mean
you came everywhere like 300 shows in
like
196 it's way too crazy it's no it's too
hard to like have a healthy home life
right and then do that it's it's tough
man
um
I uh have my relationship with we have a
deal like we don't spend more than two
weeks apart that's a good one and we've
been breaking the rule a lot with that
and it's hard because with the tour bus
you know like it doesn't make sense to
go out for just two weeks yeah yeah it
makes more sense to go for three weeks
yeah you ever fly her out yeah yeah for
sure yeah yeah
um she's invited everywhere I go all the
time no matter what how you guys been
together almost six years almost six
years yeah wow that's a long time I know
it's my first time I ever made it to one
year really yeah
this is the first time I know that my
previous record was like 10 months in a
relationship your whole life yeah wow
and now uh
I've got I've got the one dude good for
you man yeah thank you congrats that's
awesome yeah dude
um
so uh how long have you been married
we are at
um 14 years 14 years of marriage of
marriage how long were you together
before we got married like three and
change I think uh-huh it's a long time
young that's pretty young right young
hearts beat fast I mean I was yeah we
started dating when I was 25. wow yeah
maybe you're 43 now
um you uh you're
coming I'm coming everywhere tour
um do you know what the special is going
to be called No I just shot it I shot it
two weeks ago
um we're at in Phoenix at the Celebrity
Theater okay
um so I shot four there I've never shot
four before uh four shows for one
special yeah all my friends started
doing it and I got kind of like
I want to know what that feels like and
it is kind of a game changer because
I think what actually happens is
knowing that you have four
actually
helps you on like show one do you know
what I mean like right most I've shot a
bunch of specials you gotta get the
Jitters out on the first one you're like
all right and then the second one is the
one and then like
all sudden I know I have four it's like
the first show was like unbelievable and
I go
I actually think it was unbelievable
because I know I have four right you
know I mean like I don't think I could
actually I don't think I would have had
the same experience if it if I had
we had this guy dude you know the
celebrities in the round right it's a
it's a theater in the round right okay
so I'm like
it's Unique in the sense that I'm
actually almost moving the entire
special like you know at some in some
way like pacing
and you know in any direction there's
audience so like you turn here there's a
lot you know and I'm walking this way
and at one point it's like I'm walking
across the stage and I look here and I
see somebody going
like this right like at the back and I
just to myself I'm like this is going to
be a problem right like I'm like so I
just keep going performing here and it's
like I hit some punchline you know it's
like laughs and then there's a dip right
there's the natural lull of like that
bit is over
and as it's like about to tr the guy
goes Tommy
Tommy and I'm like
yes
hello
he's like what's up man and I'm like
what's up dude and he goes no yeah and I
go you think this is the time to do this
like you're at and he goes it is what it
is
and I was like yeah I guess it is and
then you just see like security come
right and then after the show I'm like
what was up and they go they couldn't
understand why we were throwing them out
and I'm like really they're like yeah we
were just saying what's up I'm like so
[ __ ] up you know you're like
I just saw a Carrot Top Show recently
how was that I loved it I loved it in
Vegas in Vegas yeah and uh somebody
piped up with something and he just says
he says oh hey yeah I'm not busy at all
right now
it's like I'm not busy at all what's
going on dude and it was just so
masterful man he's um
underrated for like how seasoned a
performer the man is too criminally
underrated is uh a title I'm yeah like
the guy's a punch line to a lot of
people and you're like this guy has been
[ __ ] hammering this [ __ ] he's 91.
he's so funny man he's a funny dude and
those Concepts like yeah coming up with
that [ __ ] right they just dismiss him as
like prop you know it's like it's and
you're like do you know the thought that
it takes to come up with that [ __ ] to
get a laugh out of that like yeah I love
it yeah I think it's I think he's
actually a very funny dude he's great we
we uh had him on the podcast
it was fantastic and it performed like
bananas yeah I mean not bananas but well
yeah it was it was how [ __ ] jacked is
he not So Much Anymore oh he toned it
down yeah he went crazy for it I was
like Steve brought it up and I probably
want to broach the subject yeah this is
something by the way that is going on
more and more
where I can't say somebody I can't
because of the fact that
they were so adamant
where like someone some dude's getting
like super crazy jacked and they're like
I don't want to talk about
right that and you're like okay but
it's like yeah I brought it up with
Karen top and he said he said yeah the
camera adds 10 pounds
but here's the thing like these dudes
like the most famous dudes in Hollywood
right in in in like action movies Chris
Hemsworth Hemsworth The Rock I mean the
rock is Juiced to the gills and you're
like he's fifth 48 yeah he's he's well
over 50 now oh really and but here's the
thing man like when you're when you're
this size when you're he's like six four
six five and you're 265 of just muscle
no body fat and I mean you're chiseled
like you you know you're the the the
human body doesn't just like naturally
do this except for in like the most rare
spectacular cases right Francis nangana
exactly something like that but what's
weird is like the complete reluctance
to say like yeah I am I'm juicy it's
like hey kids this body takes half a
million a year to get to like why not be
he's exactly 50.
50 years old right and like you know you
know 50 walking around like that is
crazy but what I'm saying is like why
why are we pretending first of all
there's a couple of things like if you
think that if you just got on a cycle
you're gonna look like the rock you're
out of your goddamn mind right it takes
like an incredible amount of work and
dedication and discipline to get there
but why are we all pretending right all
these dudes aren't on [ __ ] it's [ __ ]
crazy and they are like don't talk about
it right all right and um what uh
I think this came out on the Netflix
show killer Sally which which I quite
enjoyed they said that there was like a
bodybuilding competition and then all of
a sudden they they made it mandatory no
steroids for like two years and like
visibly like they just weren't so
impressive anymore and they were like
okay screw that everyone back on
nobody wanted to see these guys there's
a lot of these dudes that are like you
don't just don't talk about the fact
that I'm on [ __ ] and you're like it was
one of my favorite things when I um
you know who Mark Bell is Mark smelly
Bell he's like uh he was a world-class
power lifter now he's like a fitness he
developed a slingshot which is this like
yeah thing that you know you can helps
like bench press
and like when I first met him I was like
we were looking at like these photos of
him doing these crazy power like 1200
pound squats and [ __ ] and you're like
Jesus [ __ ] cry like and he's like
well you know I'm on like 20 Peds like
you know like I'm I'm on all this [ __ ]
but like here's the thing so he's like
yeah I'm on that [ __ ] but also like you
also go like yeah you know that if you
took that [ __ ] you're not squatting that
like the guy right it's a combination of
the thing but he's not going
oh I never took anything like the people
live in this fantasy of like
yeah own it yeah like Schwarzenegger is
like yeah we all did steroids that's
what we like when people were like you
just stare he's like we all we all did
them like do you think that if you did
steroids you would look like Arnold
[ __ ] Schwarzenegger like it's not
it's not that easy man part of me thinks
that it should be a requirement for
professional athletes to take
performance-enhancing drugs I mean who
doesn't want to see an enhanced
performance I mean I mean dude baseball
in like 2006 when like Mark Maguire
Barry Bonds and Sammy Sosa were crushing
home runs like that was the best time in
baseball it's the only time I've ever
watched baseball yeah exactly I can't
stand baseball I just want to see them
[ __ ] crash home runs yes I want to
see people Roid Rage and like break bats
over their [ __ ] head or knee or yeah
like get pissed and throw Gatorade onto
the field and but like for instance
that's an anomaly Bo Jackson that's a
guy that could do that [ __ ] steroid free
he's a freak of nature he can run
sideways on walls yeah that's a once in
a generation type of person but
everybody else is probably looking at
like how do I do that steroids yeah
nobody's broken a bat over their knee in
a long time have they not that I've seen
he did that [ __ ] with ease I know dude
imagine that he would do it like it was
a twig he was like damn and just like
snap a bat over his knee yep who knows
man I would love and then you wouldn't
play football yeah they said that he
would show up to Camp right and Camp is
like grueling and it's when you you
think you're in shape right like players
will stay in shape then they get to camp
and they're like I'm not in game shape
you know and that Beau would show up
like three weeks late to camp
and right out of the gate would just be
blown by ever they were like
like it was like he didn't even need
Camp That's crazy dude
um so
you're home for a second and just back
out on tour uh back on tour tomorrow
um it is the end of my actual no
I have sorry man I have three more weeks
of domestic touring
and then it's over December 4th and then
I do Hawaii for New Year's and then next
year is all International dates and it
ends in May
wow so you're gonna
have this special in the
the same show and then well the thing is
like they're um we're discussing when to
release it so like I don't know is it
gonna be Netflix yeah okay yeah it's a
Netflix special
um it'll come out I don't know when
it'll come out we have to talk about it
but is it are you doing that Netflix
deal where you own it and you're
licensing it to them no all right okay
congrats that's uh yeah no I did a
different deal yeah you think they have
that deal no that's the thing that
they've been doing they've been doing
the thing yeah that's a big thing
they're doing now is that they're
it's a licensing deal they yeah for sure
that's killer man what can we promote
for you
um you know
um a bunch of international dates are
coming up we've been moving to like to
bigger but we're doing some Arenas in
the UK in London and Dublin and Glasgow
and then
um yeah the UK is our second biggest
audience yeah huge huge audience there
um we moved to bigger places in Berlin
and Paris and Vienna
um I'm doing some bigger places in Paris
and Vienna yeah that's that's pretty
Vienna is going to be more
English-speaking but not Paris Paris
what ends up happening though is like
when I well because I did some of these
markets last time is the people that
come to these shows oh like I'm doing
also doing Latin I'm doing Chile Peru
and Mexico City I'm looking at Mexico
City yeah the people that come are easy
either expats or biling you know they're
fluent English speakers you know so they
actually end up being better audience
than you imagine will come to the show
um so yeah I just you know I have those
dates and obviously podcasts all you
know all the time yeah yeah
it's epic dude and we missed we missed a
crucial MRI to do this to do this yeah I
can't thank you enough dude I might
wither away just because I didn't
yeah well dude I love you man love you
too man thanks thanks brother can I take
a moment to Express gratitude that Tom
Segura skipped the opportunity to have
that crucial MRI so that he could do the
Wild Ride podcast with me what a bro and
what great people you are who stick
around to the very end you know I love
you oh and by the way my dad's in town
careful about that white board Big Time
plans going on back there ah yeah man
and uh candidly we shot this today in
Austin and clearly I'm back home already
I had a long and uh fruitful day and I
love you thank you for sticking around
I'm going to bed with Lux